you know trevor williams over his last
two starts has really impressed me cesar
hernandez leads off batting left-handed
called third strike well done good start
two down now for francisco lindor
better and did he go
yup he did that's trip gibson bringing
up lindor a couple of punch-outs for
trevor williams one two three go the
indians shane bieber takes the hill for
the indians tonight making his sixth
start he's four-and-oh and a brilliant
130 earned run average uh coming off a
great game against detroit where he went
seven innings gave up three hits he
struck out 11 and walked just once eric
gonzalez in the lead off spot tonight
swinging a mess through the fastball by
him and another strikeout for bieber
number 55 in 35 innings of work so josh
bell with a runner and scoring position
and one out
swung on and missed he got a piece of it
but bo taylor hung on
friend mio reyes
slow chopper that's going to stare about
there yes yeah and it's a base hit for
friend male reyes here's beau taylor the
left-handed hitting catcher swing and a
liner by bo taylor toward the gap in the
right center it gets down for a base hit
that'll score reyes naquin is on his way
to third and bo taylor has his first hit
as an indian it's a two out rbi single
to right center here's gerard dyson the
left-handed hitter
and it's straight three called fastball
in the inside corner locked them up
trevor williams to cesar hernandez who
bangs it on the ground to first a dive
toward the line smothered by bellen on
his belly kind of a half crawl and tags
the bag well what a play by bell to take
a double at least away from cesar
hernandez going toward the line jacob
stallings at 262. he's got four runs
matted in
got him looking for strikeouts for
bieber first time through the pirates
order newman has an eight-game hitting
streak
2-2 dribbled past the mound toward third
ramirez bare hands and flips onto first
wildly but santana cuts it off it's
gonna be an infield hit for newman the
big basher josh bill struck out his
first time up
and a good pitch first they try to steal
third and gonzalez is a dead duck
gonzalez thought he could catch the
indians
napping with that shift to the right
trying to steal third and beau taylor
with a perfect throw in ramirez on the
run to get over there was able to catch
that throw on the run and tag out eric
gonzalez the pitch
a swing and a miss he chased a slider in
the dirt taylor picks it up flips to
first josh bell swung at ball four shane
bieber works out of it they are loaded
top of the order in cesar hernandez
got him looking
number five colin moran leads off for
pittsburgh here in the fourth
did he go they appeal and he went too
far says tripp gibson wow
i'll tell you what the hitters tonight
he's been ejected from the game jose
osuna oh for one flight to right his
only time up
as bieber gets his seventh strikeout of
the night cole tucker will lead off for
the pirates here in the fifth inning
yes i think that
eighth strikeout for bieber nice and
cold strike three pour the fastball
right in there and now the pirates have
runners at the corners so adam frazier
will bat left-handed hitter and it's a
check swing and a ball in the dirt
appeal at third he went around big
strikeout for bieber that's his tenth oh
for two tonight
swing and a miss tried to hold up and
chased another wicked slider off the
outside part of the plate huge strikeout
for bieber number 11. here's jt riddle
right field naquin
and bieber gets out of a jam here in the
sixth the pirates get him at the corners
with nobody out but cannot score
hit hard to right tucker gonna be tested
oh
the no look catch for call tucker
try not to smile
try not to smile cole
what a play
taking a peek on the scoreboard
hn super mo look you see this hand go
out trying to feel for it he felt the
track hand goes out
i mean he was just hitting it yeah he
did just cutting the glove and then he
looked up that was great
oh man
so the indians have loaded them up
taylor had an rbi single to right center
in the second inning with two down
that's the game's only run and the 1-1
a swing and a smash on the ground of
first
fielded by bell wide throw to the plate
and he pulled the foot of stallings off
the plate sliding in safely as reyes
will get an argument and according to
home plate dump ben may
he pulled his foot and the pirates are
asking for this to be reviewed in new
york and i think it's the right call
when you look at the replay but i tell
you what if nothing else ben may had a
great look at it he was in good position
so from that standpoint
it looks like he made the right call but
we'll see what they say in new york
the call is not overturned
wow
two-nothing indians so that'll bring up
the pinch hitter for gerard dyson john
ryan murphy
straight three called fastball got him
rosie and i are homeless but the indians
sweep the pirates two to nothing and
that is shut out number five for the
indians tops in the major leagues and
it's the fourth time this year the
indians have won a game two to nothing
they sweep the pirates to extend their
winning streak to sixth straight
two-nothing tribe over pittsburgh